I want to bring in Janet shamlin who's
been speaking with members of the
community Janet good morning David good
morning to you Nashville is gripped by
grief this morning as word of the horror
sweptice Community we were here talking
to people who came to pay tribute
pilgrimages that started in the
afternoon and lasted late Into the Night
as the sun set on one of Nashville's
most heartbreaking days the wounds are
fresh and emotions raw I'm a substitute
teacher too so it really hit home for
can happen anywhere many grieved in
churches that organized vigils others
privately some came here to the Covenant
School these periods their lives are
changed forever today
forever and that's why I'm here at
school is supposed to be a safe thing
you know Shondell Brook's son all day is
a student nearby what did you think when
you heard about this today my heart
dropped Brooks knows the unimaginable
pain of losing a child her older son
died due to gun violence five years ago
and it's sad to say that
we are being pushed into a club that we
never asked to be a part of
get out here in so many ways
cross out the school
we got three nine-year-old babies that
aren't going to make it home tonight
that's police officer Russell Ward on
the job at what is now a crime scene
but with the same
parents everywhere
come today while you're standing out
absolutely I got kids got grandkids you
know they're all in school and anytime
you get it's something that's involving
a child it just magnifies it and
everybody and it it touches everybody
deeply
indeed
there is no recovery from the loss of a
child you live with it every day for the
those were awards from another mother I
spoke to last night she also lost her
son she came here to grieve for all the
victims she said but especially for the
parents of those three nine-year-olds
moms and dads waking up this morning
with a life that's forever changed it's
Unthinkable David Shannon champion thank
you